all right we got kind of quite a group
today don't we
all right
i'm dragging nine poor fools out into
the rain in the middle of alaska here
and uh we decided this is perfect
weather to sleep without tents you guys
wanna go build shelters yeah
well we're gonna go do a little hiking
we're gonna camp do a little fishing and
try not to get hypothermia
first thing we got to do is cross this
little creek here and at least one of us
thought to bring waiters
brotherly love right there
[Applause]
that's cold
and pointy
now the fun part
well there we go we got everybody across
the river without anyone falling in
that that's a bit of salmon right there
those looks like a good spot to camp you
got that unclipped
we're going to need somebody to gather a
lot of firewood if you guys can't snap
it over your knee it's probably not dry
enough
tom will you take this over to the
building material pile yes
look at that that is a huge piece of
cottonwood bark that's actually worth
some money right there so how about this
guys why don't you start gathering
firewood and put it all right down here
okay
do me a favor
dig a big hole i want a big enough hole
that you could bury your brother in it
okay
bring me your driest wood smallest stuff
dry stuff
oh
[Music]
you guys do you need some ketchup
well the weather cleared up a lot more
than i was expecting
actually see the mountains
i've been gathering
here
okay
well
washed up big silver
um
there you go you guys got that 10 up
oh there you go there you got some room
under that thing
fill the bladder full of water screw
this in
gravity pulls it through
then you're just go and
pinch it off and there you go we got
water
this right here is all sliced apples and
sliced peaches with brown sugar and
butter
here tom hold this
there we go that's all porked ribs i
rubbed them and seasoned them up last
night
i got about eight pounds of pork ribs
buried in the sand i'm gonna let that
sit for about three hours and hopefully
it's edible we'll see never done this
before
we got the apples the peaches the sweet
potatoes the corn the ribs all buried
under coals you guys having fun
the food's cooking the kids are playing
mark and his brothers are fishing i'm
gonna clean up this beach a little bit
hey tim what'd you find let me see that
a japanese ball back before plastic was
readily available the japanese would
blow glass balls to float their gill
nets and they still wash up on shore
from time to time tim just found one
congratulations that thing's probably
like 70 80 years old
come over the boys are trying to smash
them like no don't smash it see right
here
see this is a rose hip
see you want them where they're you want
them where they're all red with no
orange on them they're kind of squishy
this one's a little under ripe i got the
boys picking berries for our breakfast
in the morning
there's tons and tons of rose hips over
there
well we're getting some hits on the rods
we might get some fish here
oh we got a fish yeah we got one yeah
god look really good oh look at this
oh that's a lake trout
beautiful little lake trout
there he goes
dog's not skunked right there
hey are you guys getting hungry
oh yeah yeah yeah all right should we
check this out see what we got
look
are those little red things rose hips
yeah here in a few months
better with corn
i couldn't do better in an oven
we've got seasoned pork ribs
we've got baked peaches and apples and
sugar and butter
got fresh corn
and we got yams with brown sugar and
butter there you go tom
there you go
do you guys have enough
what do you think of the food very
delicious you guys like the food yes
the wind died down and the gnats came
out
yeah welcome to alaska
oh yeah
you lay it fast
in the water leave them in the water
oh look at that beautiful trout
there we go
beautiful lake trout
it's not bad i've never fished here
before feel it fast fast fast fast feel
it faster faster faster
oh another little lake trout
there we go
on the spinner huh
that is that that's probably the biggest
lake trout we've got today
there we go biggest fish of the day yeah
yeah look at that
first alaskan lake trout what do you
think good
well while we've been reeling in lake
trout after lake trout the boys have
started doing war games
i'm in the bunker
boys are having a ball
oh it's a baby
oh this has been pretty nice i was
expecting it to be nasty weather the
whole time and this has turned out
really quite pleasant but it's getting
late i think it's time to get the kids
down to bed
[Music]
okay
listen are you guys all cozy
[Music]
everyone get laid down
lay down they're not going with me
well now the kids are down i've got a
lot of little chores to do i got to
clean this place up
get all this food packed away and fish
bait put away got to finish drying some
clothes get those packed away just kind
of tidy up the campsite and get
everything ready for tonight
[Applause]
another pretty little lake crowd
oh
weather turned out a lot better than we
expected didn't it oh yeah
oh that rod just got slammed that was
nice
you know these are small lake trout
we're catching we could easily run into
a big boy that's like 20 30 pounds
though okay wild animals are a problem
and it's bulls
bowls are a problem see i see you i see
you
bulls are cute but they're nasty little
things so get in and they'll chew up
your sleeping bag to steal the fluff for
their nests i even know people have had
bulls pull their hair out of their head
while they're sleeping you don't want
bowls in your tent if you see a vole you
get it rid of it figure this beach would
be too open for him but i guess i'm
wrong
i wonder how many are already in my tent
i didn't notice
nice bottle of boiling water to keep my
bag warm well i reeled up all the
fishing rods and got the campsite
cleaned up
it gets time to go get in my sleeping
bag and
call it for the night
all right guys it's getting late i'm
gonna go to bed see you guys in the
morning
good morning
you can't ask for a more beautiful
morning
but man we gotta get some breakfast
going we have a lot of kids here and
they're going to be hungry
[Music]
how did you guys sleep stuff warm yeah
it was good yeah
not a problem yeah you fit a lot of guys
in there any problems with condensation
yep
my shelter got really wet inside
it was it was wet before i even got
inside because that greenhouse effect of
the water coming up through the gravel
go ahead and get a lot of condensation
in a single walled tent this happens
hey guess who's got a fish
look at that nice
caught that one on a lake leech
[Music]
like
well this has been a really awesome
campsite
but now we gotta go hike back
and get across that river
yeah salmon there
that's what you really got to worry
about the bears walking up and down the
beach looking for that
oh hey guys did you have fun yeah yeah
awesome well listen guys i hope you
enjoyed watching this video as much as
we enjoyed doing this camping trip if
you guys want to see more adventures
from the outdoor boys youtube channel
make sure to click subscribe because we
put out new videos every saturday
morning all right
nailed it
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]